in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast it's a new
[ __ ] year the year 2020 is it the
year that Nick is actually gonna do work
for the first time ever yeah
no never you're right I'm gonna prolong
it till 2025 baby oh come on you're
allergic to success we are I want to
this is actually an intervention for you
we are sponsored by extra I'm actually
busier than ever
I like that since like since like like
summer of last year's look at him dude
cuz you know before we would train right
and I'm like what you got going on for
the rest he goes absolutely he's [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I'm like what well what's
this hold what am I doing here - that at
the time it was like I'm studying for my
test that's yes I would dude I had
clients bro really I just say this
barely passed barely be passed by a
[ __ ] ball thread yeah that's what
happened I'm all hair ramires reading he
was studying he was so stressed and I
was like nah dude you're good you're
[ __ ] you gonna you're gonna nail it
and I'd leave I bet dude behind closed
doors you felt that way yeah wow wow
yeah have a seat
you know I in the middle of the test I
took a nap I took like a little power
nap bro have a garden I mean you need
vitamins in your life I haven't been
fall asleep like that anymore I really
don't do that anymore asked if she'll
tell you about all her videos are you
asleep it's the thousand in 2019 bro she
has one of you at a restaurant here in
the middle of a sentence you follow some
would like to order those are all dude
vitamins those are old I've been
sleeping great and I feel great when you
fall asleep in public it looks like
somebody sniped you from a distance no
seriously
well that's it that's how that was a if
I was in a car forget about it I'm out
that used to be the norm if I say if I
if somebody was driving and I'm in the
passenger seat or sometimes if I was
driving I get really sleepy yeah
when I went to school at Northridge and
it was about like a 20 30 minute commute
I would have to like eat on the way from
school to work because if I didn't eat
something during the drive I'd want to
fall asleep and happy yeah like I have
to whine down the windows and have to
yell like like a psychopath and slap my
face to keep here how did you just pull
over and take a nap you [ __ ] bro cuz I
got ya cuz uh one it's like it's like a
challenges like you know I can get
through oh yeah do [ __ ] everybody else's
life I've never fallen asleep kills the
pain also it's like I had to be at work
at a certain time so it was like
literally I had 30 minutes to get to
work and I had to be there so where did
you work I was that bike Adam and I work
a fight again you did not live that far
from fight academy to falsely no no from
around the corner you lived here at
Lowe's no that was that when I would
commute from school to find Academy cuz
after class I would go straight to the
gym and teach like a frickin nerd like a
frickin idiot but you know what I
haven't been fall asleep which is great
I feel highly doubt that yeah no I swore
all next time TIFF is on here you ask
her she she wishes anytime she can get
me fall asleep and take a video of it
she'll explain me no matter what so
joke's on you do it I would like my
videos don't look that you fall asleep
so have you always been able to fall
asleep like that because I can't fall
asleep to say my [ __ ] life man yeah
but not anymore though like now it's
like I can't fall asleep at night it
takes a lot because you [ __ ] sleep
the whole day this is a false narrative
and I'm not gonna stand for it dude bro
coffee shop once I'm literally chillin
like a new man brah changed I've been
eating the iron and it's deny any
[ __ ] meets up with me it's like a
let's kick it we'll get some work done
Bob like we literally just talked like
this like for like five minutes there's
a guard I'm gonna get some work done Naz
like me too I started doing my thing and
I look over literally 45 seconds later
and this [ __ ] asleep like just
like this is not
literally we told this story before and
I defended myself accurately okay and he
didn't even know I fell asleep I told
him I fell asleep next story you fell
asleep in the position in which you're
trying to fool a teacher that you still
awake literally on the last podcast I
explained how I used to cheat like this
looking at other people's tests and
that's how I fell asleep and he even
know I fell asleep I told them so it
doesn't matter joke's on you my friend
that [ __ ] in b12 invited him to work
that the audacity yeah right well he was
always over there that was his coffee
shop that was that was his mother yeah
why can't you go there more dated in one
of the breezes it didn't work out bro
you're I'm doing better I'm doing you
know me common jobs you can't go to
anymore cuz this is we can go we don't
go you know what the funny thing is if
you go in Pasadena and you look at the
walls it's just a wanted poster of Pat's
dick dick with two googly eyes yo the
coffee shop that's down up to the street
from me literally a block I can't go to
any more you can go I don't know dude
and I feel weird now I feel weird don't
feel weird she's cool I know she's loose
use a sweetheart I liked her a lot
it didn't end badly it just was kind of
like I don't know it just was it was
just weird you can't like [ __ ] everybody
dude I'm trying not to sky every every
other week
no he's banging it's not true I wish it
was that easy for me literally yes every
every girl I talked lime with went and
they come up and they start talk to him
and I'm they're just googly eyes no they
love you do not you yeah he's full of
[ __ ] see that isn't one of those monster
girls there and then originally she's
faced towards both you and their
soulless you start shifting over to bad
[ __ ] boba drink and put that I'm like
this policy it's like what was nice guys
going on hey what's your favorite Bubba
shops and they just look anyway you're a
good wingman dude yeah dude I am he's
the best he's the best I just sleeps
yeah
great hey Nick shut the [ __ ] up for a
second I just got you but by the time
you said that I'm already like nose-up
I'm asleep mouth breather that's why I
thought it was for a while
TIFF was like you got to get the surgery
you get the the deviated septum surgery
you have a deviated septum for the app
cuz I can't breathe out of my nose
I'm a mouth breather you can't breathe
out of your nose I could breathe out a
one nostril but it's just not what
besides that way see that smashed in too
many times well the craze that's like a
fat person to be able to eat the dumbest
thing I've ever heard of my life since I
was a kid I would I wouldn't be able to
breathe out of my nose and my dad would
try to take me to this Chi doctor
[ __ ] duty doctors are the funniest
human beings on earth he would do this
he would just float his hand and do this
and then I was like eight and I would
just sit in this chair and then just
hate my life because it was every
Saturday morning and that was off the
whole time to [ __ ] watch cartoons and
be a lazy ass I was the only time I can
watch TV it was like Saturday Sunday
I sometimes wonder like how certain
Asian people still have businesses just
because like sometimes Asian people
don't realize that they're in a business
and they just argue and fight in front
of people yesterday so I got I got I had
to get a massage because I did a light
workout with it I destroyed very light
workout massage I had to because I
couldn't move there's no what happens
when your D trained you know okay D
train is not even a word yeah dude it is
bro train is a nickname for like that
yeah but then these two so funny after I
got done with the massage and you know
like when you get into an Asian massage
they had like the music and whatever you
hear like the water trickling down it
was all great and then right when I come
down I didn't know what they were saying
in Mandarin but they were screaming at
each other and the owner was just
sitting at a chair just texting as the
two employees are screaming in front of
my face and I think it was over tips and
I'm like how the [ __ ] do you guys stay
in business yeah for sure you're sucking
dick did you go to the same massage
parlor that I went to because literally
the story doesn't start with H I don't
know it's on Val it's on Las Tunas this
lady was massaging me she picks up a
phone call she's literally like she's
not
Wow yeah she's not even trying to
massage me with one hand she just just
stops completely and she just has a
conversation and I'm just sitting there
and then she's selling progressive cards
it's just like massage depends on what
kind of coverage you do you have a 2007
Honda Element
they said give me a simple maybe study
found that doesn't have any words
totally right actually yeah it was a
trip so he probably into the same place
where did you go
I went to a spot I actually liked it a
lot I won't shout their name waste look
it's the one that we've talked about the
one on Green Street yes really that's
they usually have amazing service
exactly but but the masseuses were
[ __ ] screaming at each other men and
it had to be over tip did you get a
couples massage no I got my regular
massage those ten dollars more yeah but
they always do a great job dude yeah and
it's so funny to like Asian people when
they find a spot that hurts they'd like
to [ __ ] it up even more
that's like we're thinking they're like
is it pinching my here am i a lot of
tension okay don't worry if you cried
that's pain leaving a [ __ ] a space
don't worry mother [ __ ] oh you're like
oh my god dude that happen to me one
time I was in Ecuador I fell off a bike
mountain biking with my [ __ ] friend
who was like an experienced mountain
biker I wasn't I ate [ __ ] [ __ ] my
shoulder up and he like there brought a
masseuse to the house like they had like
his family was rich and this lady comes
in I was like hey can you please not
touch my shoulder like my shoulders like
a little banged up she's a no no that's
good like well just massage it out it's
fine
this [ __ ] spent an hour on my [ __ ]
collarbone and also had her like
henchmen she brought like surf games
dude there was some guy who thought I
was wearing a [ __ ] Where's Waldo like
red and white and he just kept massaging
my calves going s oh I see which
basically means yes in Spanish like yeah
there you go and I saw it was kind of I
was in pain and
getting molested at the second rock hard
it's [ __ ] terrible popping out of his
where's waldo sure yeah lotion smells a
lot like come dude yes was like
bleaching here what's going on [ __ ]
the what were you doing in Ecuador I
just put the friend like we went to go
visit he has family in Equatorial was
like a you want to go and I was like
yeah my buddy did a Peace Corps in
Ecuador for two [ __ ] years man he
says like the coastal areas are nice but
then he was like in a village area but
he says Ecuador can get [ __ ] crazy
dude yeah he gets [ __ ] wild over
there yeah for sure it's good for fun
yeah I mean he had family in Quito they
were rich so like I gots a bunch of cool
[ __ ] like elaborate [ __ ] cool [ __ ]
but we went to like the coast went to
the Amazon which was dope we went like
river rafting and like dude you went to
the [ __ ] Amazon it's like Jurassic
Park in real life like everything can
kill you butterflies are [ __ ] like
chihuahuas silent river rafting dude and
it was dull long were you there for like
a month almost with Diego I won't force
was I knew is the egg off the top our
ship flipped it was [ __ ] crazy weight
went how long ago was this like five
years ago oh dude I remember that I
remember that that's probably a member
gives a [ __ ] Pat whatever and I'm on the
plane he's like dude the Amazon [ __ ]
scares the [ __ ] out of me dude I heard
like the whole Amazon will put sighs the
fact that is burning or something like
that but that's Australia I think
Australia is now I think I thought
Amazon was burning like we saw yeah
that's true was it's always sorry burn
everything is burning everything's burnt
everything catching on fire we're all
done apparently it's like it happens
every you know this podcast is brought
to you by attitude my friends if you
have a great mattress you should also
have amazing amazing sheets that go
along with it edit two sheets have
caressed my naked body for quite a while
now and I got to tell you nothing will
touch this body unless it's an attitude
BAM boo eco sheet yes my friends I love
my attitude sheets you know there are
times when I have to wash my editor
sheets so I have to use my backup sheets
and they're made of content and I want
to burn them into the the center of the
Sun that's how much I hate those sheets
compared to my attitude
I love them listen my friends if you
have not heard of clean bamboo before
it's the holy grail of fabric
once you go bamboo you won't go shoo
shoo
I did not think that went through but
anyways guys there uh may sing and by
the way if you didn't know antimicrobial
and better for the environment organic
clean bamboo recycles ninety-eight
percent of the water it uses so it's the
most sustainable bedding uh vailable
cotton uses a ton of pesticides and
waste water and is harmful on the
environment so why not try attitude
these amazing sheets have a 30-day
risk-free trial if you're not fully
satisfied you can return your sheets for
a full refund they even cover shipping
on returns added to sheets they're soft
as silk breathable as linen but at the
price of cotton you're going to love
them when you support our sponsors you
support our show and right now my
listeners will get 20% off their sheets
set and free shipping just text brain 2
6 4 - 0 0 0 the only way to get 20% off
your set of attitude sheets and free
shipping is the text brain - 6 4 - 0 0 0
that's B raim - 6 4 - 0 0 0 message and
data rates may apply question is it
flame-retardant or flavor tarded
retardant claim [ __ ]
cuz I have been calling you a flame
[ __ ] for the longest time what would
the [ __ ] part of that mean though
huh well with that what would that mean
flame retardant did means that it can't
catch on fire because jackets [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah yeah that is what it means
jackets [ __ ] can't catch no it's not
[ __ ] its retardant okay I'd like to
apologize I'd like to make a public
apology I like to do my Kevin wait or
wait nobody nobody you like corrected
you on that everyone just my friends are
[ __ ] so they just let me just walk
around calling things [ __ ] I
honestly thought it was that - I know
you're full of [ __ ] this is not a fit
right this is serious
I honestly is fully empowered your your
flame retardant bro that's like the next
I found out on this podcast that PZ do
does not be
sake of this podcast I will say this
that I found out through this podcast
that [ __ ] is a no se word now yeah
you got to say our word yes and I didn't
know that so I was just stoned out the R
word like crazy man I'm a [ __ ] sub
chromosome but I didn't know that it was
a not like proper word yeah because I
because for me it's an adjective that
can be used outside of using it for a
person mm-hmm right yeah I am [ __ ]
is what I thought that's exactly I
thought well that wasn't that was my
defense and they're like no it's [ __ ]
and they looked at you crazy and I was
like is this person [ __ ] with me so I
looked it up on Google and I'm like I'm
living in this [ __ ] bear stealing
world so you typed in flame retardant
and then said I was like hey Siri and he
responded back I'm serious I think I
think that's a 2019 thing like you can't
say [ __ ] yeah it works you got a
dance is if that's a dangerous one
that's it yeah cuz I assume because it
could be used for you know like an
inanimate object I mean your phone's not
working like this phones being [ __ ]
cousin you're not saying it as if it's
that you can't catch on fire yes exactly
right because it's not an attribute that
I'm saying that it's for a human being
I'm just using it as the adjective for
what the definition of the word is but I
didn't know that's I say my phone was
gay like that no that's different
because that is different well that's
the same way you know like it's the same
thought process yeah so I [ __ ] up
apologies world they use the term used
to be [ __ ] idiot
that's so mad back let's break that yeah
like that was the original like we
originally like the door I mean there
might have been something before that
bully handicap yet before back in the
day it was like slightly Hanson a
science textbook mental disability and
they'd be like oh this is a [ __ ]
idiot now I'm like it's like people
called [ __ ]
what is a [ __ ] I think I'm moms
Aloha
is the scientific term for like certain
races right so you have like flat-faced
okay like Glenny i tink you know
economists know I think [ __ ] is
actually the scientific term for Asian
people is it yeah Caucasoid is for white
people really hot so it is that word
comes from you know I know a lot of
things but I have to double check this
[ __ ] listen [ __ ] kakizou it ass
yeah it is weird too
yeah that's that's a reptilian like they
couldn't think of anything else yes
[ __ ] relating to the broad division
of humankind including the indigenous
peoples of East Asia Southeast Asia and
the Arctic region so people were calling
Asian people [ __ ] Wow [ __ ] I
think I think well I think the idiot
part is long got to be [ __ ] idiot
just because so they yeah so they were
like so if it was a white dude they
would be like a [ __ ] idiot call
them an a like an Asian idiot do look a
little come on soon this guy dude oh
yeah this man hold pads we were just
cracking jokes about you know it's so
funny cuz so they do this imitation of
me like my punch or like when I hit
mints or something like that and Alex
Alex shout to Alex a Costa he does such
a spot-on imitation of me that I can't
even be mad at well he didn't know about
your nose disability which is why you
have to breathe through your mouth like
a [ __ ] goldfish yeah it's swallow air
you hear that this man breathes like air
is like a piece of meat and he's biting
out tifa's like she's losing sleep over
it she can't sleep so you you show her a
lot I don't snore but like I snore when
I'm sleeping up if I'm sleeping on my
side I'm good
so she'll she'll wake me up in the
middle of the night if I'm snoring if
I'm laying upright and then she'll be
like hey you're snoring al sorry babe
and I'll turn and I won't snore but
that's about it
dude what's it like sleeping in your own
bed it's been a while man yeah
my man's nice it's nice actually I just
I just moved so I mean I was sleeping in
my own bed anyways
but it's [ __ ] nice dude I like it but
also but I like when someone likes
sleeps over like if a girl sleeps over
it's actually kinda yeah all nine of
them but I Patrick I guess it's the
choice like it's a choice like if you
have to sleep next to somebody like when
I was living with the girl I was like
[ __ ] [ __ ] like [ __ ] dude [ __ ] Muriel
has this thing where I feel like all
girls like their body temperature is way
lower than a man's body so she has this
Korean heat blanket that's like $300
right well the thing is you could sear a
steak on it and so it covers up 75% of
the bed so I just have this sliver where
I can survive and they said like I like
the funny thing is like she always
mentions that that heat mattress as my
Savior because I used it during the time
I had the flu and she goes like well I
guess you like it now I'm dying [ __ ]
how dare you shove that in my face and
I'm actually dying you were dehydrated
while you were sleeping on that blanket
and that's why you got sick it was like
there's video of her she recorded like
giving me [ __ ] about me using her heat
blanket as I had the flu she's like well
look who's a weight down trying to get a
brandy like a [ __ ] wet cloth on my
head like a acne cartoon she still has
to mention how she's right about the
heat yeah as I'm [ __ ] dying dude as
she's shoving in your face I hate that
[ __ ] because how does Muriel sleep at
night does she like
did she move around a lot she talks in
her sleep and she has punched me to my
face multiple times which at this point
I am assuming now that she's just doing
it on purpose
I think she's stalking me in the face of
pretending like she's asleep
she sucks here and then just like falls
asleep yep I've definitely elbowed her
in her [ __ ] before just didn't even
wake up she just played it off she's
like I'm not gonna give him the
satisfaction you see her toes tense up
dude TIFF sleeps with no pillows well I
know she's crazy and she sleeps in a
ball so it's like she's the best partner
sleep with that's all he does he sleep
in a ball I don't know she just likes
hugging her legs and she cuddles
position her like yeah like kind of in a
famous position like honor on enos a
fetus obviously the Phoenix position
basically gets up as she floats up in
the sky bears in the fire yeah yeah so
she seems like that
but she also takes all of the blankets
all of the blankets oh we got two
planets now because that [ __ ] I had
we have five blankets and she takes all
of the blankets what did you do is the
question she hates you she just well she
just turns she takes a blanket and turns
his roll top and she a man she even by
the time with the by the time it's like
midnight cuz we sleep at nine o'clock
every night but time it's midnight all
the blankets on her side
jiu-jitsu do they Sergey Jisoo defense
yeah yeah and there's nothing I can do
and yeah it's no pillows huh no pillows
it's the weirdest thing ever she's like
she we also have 15 pillows on the bed
and then like 10 of them end up on the
floor yo you know what I realized this
is like some white people [ __ ] white
people have like 30 pillows on their bed
yeah why what is the knowing the
decoration I think oh is that what that
is decoration - no I mean I I don't come
from a family where that's the thing I
think it's like a rich people do I think
it's an interior design thing people
that really like interior design I feel
like have a lot of so it's not
functional they're not actually
decoration I've seen literally that
instead of matter what that setup like
where they had 46 pillows on the bed and
then like before they go to sleep they
like take 45 of them off my chest and
then go to sleep I've seen that and I'm
like why are you that's the dumbest
[ __ ] thing I've ever liked I don't
know you know what
cuz when you make the bed it makes it
look nice that's what it is
oh who gives a [ __ ] I know that's so
interesting I pull over because when I'm
at the hotel
like I always see like they put like
[ __ ] down they put 12 pillows on my
[ __ ] bed and I just get mad [ __ ]
toss that [ __ ] like it [ __ ] is it
scratchy ass pillow doing here yeah so
it's just purely for decoration yeah
it's like they're called throw pillows I
think I throw pillows I also found out
at the ED end of the the in the hotel
you have something called a bed runner
which I found out that's for you to put
your shoes on like your feet with shoes
on Oh
so why people sleep with their shoes on
yeah that's that's not okay
so yeah be ready for business
[Laughter]
that Mexican is the the Mexican cleaning
lady what that was for really I asked
her I was like excuse me like what is
this for she's like for shoes why would
it be for shoes when they sleep for
shoes like she literally showed me she
goes what I was like why people do that
she goes that is the dumbest thing I've
ever heard
yeah it's if you go to bed you're gonna
bring your shoes into the bed
that's disgusting flippers are like
actual like my night it's like when you
walk in and then you you don't want to
take off your shoes so you you ever
watch like movie sometimes and like
someone has a scene where they go in the
bed or like they're sitting and talking
on the bed they always have shoes on and
like growing up I used to be very like
dude I've seen people sleep and then
they are way I've seen people that I
know sleep in their bed with shoes on
and that's why their feet smell like
[ __ ] and it's also disgusting dude you
you step in [ __ ] you go to the bathroom
you ever been to a men's bathroom before
it's [ __ ] disgusting you're gonna
take those same shoes and go into bed
with you I don't like that have you ever
smelled a girl's foot after they put it
into a boot without socks I have what in
the [ __ ] is that about that I've never
had some [ __ ] socks on you [ __ ]
creatures dude yeah that's disgusting
yeah it's like it's date like when they
were like they're leather like Doc
Martens really yeah you know what
[ __ ] stop is that something is that a
thing I guess I don't know if there's no
space or sometimes I wear those like
little like like [ __ ] a centimeter of
sake
it does nothing and then you get that
cheese that Gouda cheese smells good at
Hooters go let's go boy you know that
the the fungus from your toes are the
same fungus that they put into cheese
it's the same bacteria so literally they
put it in toilet but it's the same
bacteria and that's why it smells the
same as cheese and they say like your
foot smells like cheese it's because
it's the same bacteria that they used to
cultivate cheese dude you're droppin
sickest facts today Wow
I know a lot of random [ __ ] you guys
know a lot of random bad runner [ __ ]
cheesy [ __ ] back to you I actually
learned that from the cleaning lady here
she's your mentor hey why does my feet
smell like cheese well just to let you
know from the choose that you put it out
there he's the same me like oh cheese
good all the kinds of cheese I'm arguing
with my wife well sometimes you get to
compromise connection it's just certain
to our [ __ ] cholas they're like
better light because when they get
louder she just done the [ __ ] shut up
that's you're a lady you have to listen
to your lady okay you know I think like
when I came to LA the the Mexican la
experience is way different from any
other place in the world yeah like
specifically that East LA accent it's
literally only in East LA yeah because
when I was on JK news every time like
Bart me or Joe we imitate somebody who's
Mexican right it's only from the type of
like like mexican-american experience
that we have in East LA and so every
time we imitate someone she goes that's
not even a Spanish accent and they're
like do a Spanish accent and but dude
that's why I like foods gone wild that
page teaches dope the best so it's funny
but everybody that lives out here
totally understands it and they all know
people that are you know that they pop I
know people that have seen their homies
on foods go wow that's [ __ ] tight you
made it this podcast is brought to you
by purple my friends if you have been
sleeping on a spring or box mattress you
are destroying your back my friends you
need a purple mattress ever since I've
had my purple mattress I have slept so
well and sleep is so important for the
next day because it helps out with your
cognitive abilities if you get good
sleep now if you didn't know this
already purple my friends backed by
rocket science rocket science is what
was used to develop this or a rocket
science develop a technology behind the
mattress same thing right am i right
friends it's firm it's soft and
keeps you really really cool at night
which my big old blubbery body needs so
check it out
hmm a hundred night risk-free trial if
you're not fully satisfied you can
return your mattress for a full refund
backed by a 10 year warranty free
shipping and returns you're going to
love purple and right now my listeners
will get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to the great free gifts they're
offering site why just Tex brain - eight
four - eight eight eight the only way to
get this free pillow is the text brain -
eight four - eight eight
that's B R a I n - eight four eight
eight eight so they have a sleigh my
coach told me this he goes do you know
what there's a song and they have a hook
where it says something about smoking
broken windows mm-hmm broken windows and
I was like what does that even mean and
he goes that's that means glass and I
was like what is that he goes that's
meth broken windows is slang for meth
and I was like holy [ __ ] that's genius
there's so much booze for [ __ ] drugs
matter there is you know what I had a
thought about yesterday and this is like
I don't think a lot of people agree with
me because I I always thought in my mind
when people said and I always thought in
my mind I always thought that when
somebody talked about like gateway drugs
I just assumed that that was [ __ ]
right like I there's no like scientific
fact to back up there's a gateway drug
that when you had this in it means that
immediately you'll do this other drug
but I had a thought the other day where
like if you just go out drinking in LA
and stuff like that recently coke and
meth huge resurgence like I don't know
why the [ __ ] everybody really everybody
that I know that they do they deal with
coke for sure and then like some meth on
the side here and there and I just see
it all the [ __ ] time when I go to
like bars in k-town or whatever and I'm
like yo this wasn't that prevalent like
people would smoke weed and they would
have [ __ ] with coke they're like
that's some that's some [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] but I just see a bunch of people
doing coke now like in the bathroom the
[ __ ] and I'm like yeah dude how do you
sorry how do you like sometimes do meth
the rabble you don't dabble in that [ __ ]
I don't know it's like it's like I think
like when people just they it now is
like when you go party
you have to party [ __ ] hard yeah so
it's like I understand when it's coke
yeah I mean I get that I guess but
there's like been this like weird
researchers for it I'm like I wonder if
it's because likely weed is so legal now
it's like if you smoke weed is like
whatever yeah I do [ __ ] coke sure
those people are losers first off if
you're just doing drugs cuz it's like
not that cool anymore
well you want to do it for the feeling
man the reason why people do coke too is
because after they drink a lot and they
need an upper no I get coke but meth
mammoth you're like tweak that's like a
party like paranoid about the government
for [ __ ] 46 hours like but a little
sometimes like I could understand I've
seen people do coke in front of me which
is also like the weirdest thing is that
why your other nostril doesn't work I
know the truth of you yeah I do a lot of
coke I wish in a glass you do what's up
window dude yeah it's a trip watching
people do I've seen people do coke in
front of me I'm only a couple of times
but it's also the weirdest thing ever
because it's weird to watch somebody to
cook in front of you want some and they
just go get a bullet they always long
they always got the key and I'm like
dude there has to be a better way a bump
as they say a bump yeah I've never part
ached but I have been around people who
do it all I think if I were to do cook
for the first time ever I'd probably add
a heart attack and die I'd be one of
those people or meth I think it would
just level you out where you stay awake
like a normal person coke so you just
stay away yeah that's what you're
missing
I stay awake I stay awake now dude like
its name an issue anymore so high I'm
sure about it that's good I'll put money
on that is 0% your put money on that
spend the day with me I'm just like half
the time you know what's funny about
Nick Nick has these random moments you
know cuz we now we train we just train
for fun we don't were not doing anything
crazy serious but there's moments where
he's just like he just wants to [ __ ]
somebody up yeah it's like this look at
his eye he's like hey guys I'm gonna
trade today am i oh you're making me
sound like a bully I don't do that do
you have you has a switch he does I've
seen it like especially when we first
start earning I remember some dude
knocked your contact out of your [ __ ]
eye some dude he was like he was like
kind of mediocre he was pretty new I
like some [ __ ] loser no you guys were
sparring but he went hard
like you okay let's take it easy and
this guy hit Nick hard and they just
beat this guy's [ __ ] ass whooped his
ass you hit him what the body shot
dropped them the guys on the floor nick
is in the mirror just trying to put his
contacts in I I've seen it Nick has it
in him sometimes when he wants to spar
I'm like everybody is gonna spar this
fool for like ten rounds mhm and we're
all heaving and dying because I even
true and I don't even know that is what
it is no your photos don't lie this
guy's full of [ __ ]
no you have this which you have it I've
seen it it's all it's okay it's only
times where I'm like I don't get to
Train and I just want to train I
shouldn't exert some energy that's all
it is
I just want you to come and beat us up
every day to be honest with you you know
fantastic because you don't know I'm
back
I need a train more this is the thing
that's why I get all like angsty and I'm
like yeah if I don't do enough but now
that I'm training for this stupid
[ __ ] marathon the dumbest thing I've
ever heard in my life dude oh you're
gonna run it I'm gonna run it Bart is
the one is the [ __ ] that's like hey
we're all gonna do it you should do it
and Mark just likes to do extreme [ __ ]
that does art but part of me was like no
dude no I told him like I'll think about
it I woke up the next day and I was like
for sure no Bart always I used to live
life on the edge he needs to feel
pressured yeah sometimes I think he's
just like on Twitter and he's just about
the type like the heinous tweet just to
have his life just [ __ ] career cancel
yeah all rape is okay wasn't really rape
question mark send it just so he could
have a little heat in the Cosby's
innocence yeah I love Bill Cosby r.kelly
remix to ignition I you know what I
actually thought about place mr Kelly at
my wedding only because I love his music
but he makes ignition you can't it's not
playing the hangar but then when I was
playing it in the house the other day I
felt a little [ __ ] did you I was like
man maybe need more people around you
you think no you do think about it cuz
I've played it too and I've been like by
myself too and I've just been like oh
like it's still a good song but like
yeah it's like a grave I think you know
like but you know
rapes the thing yeah because I you know
with Michael Jackson you can't really
prove it so I have that that deniability
what's your stance on Michael Jackson he
talked about this didn't do that nothing
you did and even if he did there's no
proof baby I know why it's because the
evidence is so circumstance dude like
it's just too wishy-washy but dude who
is hanging out with little kids like
that on the ranks I mean look if he did
do it I would not be surprised at all
yeah I would kind of be like okay I
could feel ya I'm not shocked but you
know just because of that guy Wade
Robson yeah I hurt so when I when I
first time I watched the documentary it
was the the leaving Neverland I think
right first time I watched it Finding
Neverland Finding Neverland yeah me and
TIFF we're watching it and we were like
oh my god this [ __ ] is a monster
uberta more about like leaving because
they're getting out of it I don't know
no find holes in Neverland as that was
but he's getting away from it again now
leaving for somebody watch it we were
like oh [ __ ] this this fool is for sure
sketch right and then we heard all this
like other evidence that came out saying
that these guys are kind of lying and
they had like proof that they were lying
but then part of me was like you know
what these guys may not have got like
you know molested or hey Macaulay Culkin
says he was never touched
yeah that's true and that's home alone
babe and you're not yellow I'd believe
him but this is not very touchable
that boy was cute am i right but if you
were like a lot below if you think about
Macaulay Culkin if you're a good
metafile you know that like he was a
little too high-profile yeah you
couldn't bless that dude you couldn't
use your fantasy but you're like okay
okay it'll ruin my whole enterprise
waitwait Robinson was really popular
though he was like that's true he was
like the it kid in Australia yeah who
laid Robinson I don't know see that's
why I guess you don't know that yeah but
but it's also it's mostly a tale of just
really bad parenting if that's the case
you know what's hilarious about r.kelly
though was that immature
don't you love that sentence the fact
that this man got out of jail and the
first thing he did went to an elementary
school to scope yeah do it what yeah
what do you mean you ever see okay you
should watch it you know
one of the funniest documentaries I've
ever seen in a life that's not supposed
to be fun so he leaves he got out of
jail
goes to an Ella so he got accused I
forgot which time he got accused but
make it happened 11 different the whole
doc is basically everybody knew about it
nobody said [ __ ] and that's why I find
it so [ __ ] hilarious because they're
trying to act like they're innocent
you're not innocent yeah you knew he was
raping these [ __ ] kids dude worried
about your job and then say [ __ ] they
interview the they're like his his crew
and they're just all like oh yeah no we
didn't really know who knew he was
eating gum yes she this guy was eating
baby ass all day like it was a [ __ ]
d'oeuvres
harder oh he's he said that with a
correct yes 14 year olds were the
amuse-bouche the 12 year olds were the
hoarders and the infants were the main
course that fool was a rapist do and he
would do like the crazy [ __ ] oh I mean
do him just pissing on that girl that's
like yeah basic stuff
what's up Jess what's up with that I
think you know what it is I feel like
celebrities they get everything handed
to them so much they want the
unattainable now it's like well I just
get regular [ __ ] I they're trying to
push the envelope it's like [ __ ] Ranga
tans and [ __ ] just getting [ __ ] by
rhinos and [ __ ] yeah you're pissing on
anybody before everyone pissed on no no
anything close I should know I don't do
any P doodoo related [ __ ] I'm just not
that's not my um I think I don't like
butt sex because it poop comes out of
there do you have any you guys have any
good stories about butt sex not me well
has the best Segway ever what's up with
butt sex am i right guys hey never tried
it Pat now never dude I have a terrible
[ __ ] story actually this is when he
told us the story we couldn't stop
talking about it for weeks
I as the talk of the dinner table talked
of the dude the story of my mom
Pat had sex with another woman again
check this one out this one's different
than the rest
Oh God so awesome your water yeah this
is this was no water from a very
disgusting person that we will not speak
about on this pot
see who we will not name yeah Valda
[ __ ] Valda
don't say her name more than once oh I
gotta do so much fun packaging right
extortion so I was dating this
Australian girl wasn't Wade Willis Wade
Whammer whoever the Australian yeah so I
was dating this Australian girl we were
dating it was cool she was beautiful it
was [ __ ] it was nice and she was at
my house we're hooking up and she was on
her period and I'm not really in a
period sex because like out of there's
blood and I'm not you know lucky I don't
just like I'll wait I'll wait you know I
don't mind waiting
so we're hooking up things are getting
heated and she's like okay like work I'm
like okay well how about you know I put
it in your butt like right that's why
he's so cute that's somebody's their
wrist is like the first tell ty is a
sign of a somebody's [ __ ] nervous is
when their voice is higher there like
that all innocent and she was like yeah
she was down there all bashful
now before before this I've tried like a
couple times like I and I mean it's
never really been successful like I've
done a few pumps and I'm like smelling
like doodoo and I'm like you know I
don't know every time I do it I'm like
why did I do this again like I I don't I
know I don't like it well I will tell
you this so I found out on JK news
there's a dude's gig I guess he's like a
gay gay expert or something [ __ ] like
that like any kind of gay topic that's
what he was known for on YouTube he
would talk about butt sex and [ __ ] and
then we literally had a whole episode on
JK news where he was informing us on how
to have anal sex which episode is this
one you are number wise it was like you
don't just go in and you start [ __ ]
somebody and yeah there's a whole
process you have to really clean diet
[ __ ] everything out enema clean that
[ __ ] out and then you start [ __ ] in
the ass like if you just start doing a
tan or it's gonna smell like [ __ ] that
sounds like a lot of work the horn
doesn't
teach you that they don't they just tell
you that when you stick it in the ass
it's clean and she sticks it in her
mouth yeah yes yeah I didn't know I
didn't know any of that I just went in
there like okay let's just like a
[ __ ] idiot like oh let's just see
what happens here like let's try let's
I'm feeling adventurous so man and it's
daytime too it's like 3:00 p.m. I think
that's an important detail the Sun was
still up it was a hot day there was a
raven it was growing there was blue in
the air so they were so Dookie baby
dodo so we're gonna [ __ ] we're doing
a thing right so I put it in and like
the usual I go slow you know I mean yeah
I got in there I got in there and we
started to having sex and it was like
kind of it was going well it was like oh
wow like this and I like felt like oh
wow like I'm doing something new it's
like like something a rush to yeah like
I like a housewife that did like a new
thing or something like I was like wow
like I could really be this person this
is a new chapter in my life and so we're
going at it and like I'm about to come
and I'm like hey like I tell her I mean
I notify I'm like I'm about to finish
I'm not to come and she says don't come
in my ass which I was confused because
like I'm gonna get pregnant like yeah it
seems like the ideal place to come but
okay you're already letting me do this
is pretty nice I shan't I will I'll
honor your request like yeah so a couple
pumps and I pull out and you always have
to grab and like you got to give a
couple more strokes so I'm like I'm
reaching for my dick and I look and my
dick is just covered in [ __ ] like green
doo doo green oh my god bring it's an
important detail Green 3 p.m. 3 p.m.
kaka kaka the Dookie was great the
middle of July so I go to I go to grab
and do the couple pumps but I see and
I'm like I'm horrified and I start like
dry heaving because I smell it and like
so now I'm but I'm still coming so I'm
coming and almost throwing up at the
same time you came I'm like it just
ended like zapping between dimensions
dude just look and my dick is just kind
of like it's just upset at you and I
just yeah I just didn't I didn't I just
opened the window it's wreaked in there
that is the grabbed attack horrifying
thing and said nothing I said nothing
she said nothing and I just went
upstairs shower and then you guys broke
up
yeah shortly after that she could never
look you the eye again oh you you don't
even look at me all you do is smell me
all you do is when I walk in the room
you just pinch your nose like calling me
PU [ __ ] green crayons all day with the
hug your [ __ ] you have to go eat
dinner and you're sitting there and
you're like maybe you should use a pug
the spinach everything green away from
her why would you let me have some salad
thank you poops why are you always
pooping what do you hold so much [ __ ] in
your butt all the time that's all right
it's force green pack time added about
dude that's an amazing yeah that was the
last I think that's the last time I'll
ever unless I meet a girl that's a
professional that's like hey and they do
the whole cleaning situation and I'll
think about it but other than that like
I'm pretty happy with China yeah I don't
like it at all and the reason why is
number one poops in there yeah right
that's where poop is from and it's
supposed to go out this way outgoing I
own it also the one time that I did try
it it's weird because the pressure is
right at the where the anus is but then
you because the vagina has a Kegel and
it holds the whole thing the ass
doesn't really have that sensation so I
remember like trying it I put it I was
like it doesn't feel that good and when
I pulled that I had no no poopy on my
penis but I didn't like it and I just
went to the bathroom washed it off and
then we just had regular sex after yeah
didn't like it it was her [ __ ] idea -
it just sounds like a lot huh
yeah because it was her idea I think she
kind of prepped she knows okay right so
like and she acted like it was like
maybe we should try it like I don't know
I don't know like he shouldn't like him
much either so she was like and I'm like
yeah like it doesn't feel as good as the
vagina so I'm gonna go back to the thing
that got intended but I'm curious from
the people that love it you know cuz
because it's different unless you
something you're not supposed to do so
gets you really [ __ ] horny yeah
that's like naughty it's like I mean you
asked I mean yeah Jo told a story where
he was he had a girlfriend he smells
like kimchi but he was he was [ __ ]
this girl in her ass so when he said
that when he [ __ ] same situation with
you he [ __ ] her but it wasn't his
whole cut his dick was it covered in
like [ __ ] he said that if he pulled out
and it was like a dagger and it made him
like gag yeah that might be worse on
human [ __ ] smells so bad it's unreal
yeah she especially like everyone a
least have a guy that he used to train
with us and he was in prison for a while
and he'd always say like in the toilets
in prison wouldn't have water in it so
at least the one he was at and he would
tell us like if you would [ __ ] in the
toilet they would like your inmate would
like his a mate would he yell at him
like yo throw some water on that
[ __ ] bro like oh my gosh I don't
think you know do you all this [ __ ]
crazy talk about the draft and [ __ ]
right I you know when you're talking
about like the age limit was like 25 or
26
yeah it's 35 oh [ __ ] we're fathers I do
have a bit till I get 18 to 26 to sign
up or you get like repercussions I don't
know what the [ __ ] it is or some [ __ ] or
I don't know what 18 the 26 to sign up
but the ending aid
to get drafted is 35 I'm pretty sure I'm
already on the draft if you took
financial aid you are yeah I took
financial aid when I was in college I to
my Nana late is it there like if you're
like what if you're an only child isn't
that like they don't [ __ ] with you
because because it was like I remember
there was like a Sullivan Act or
something like there was like a family
yeah you were like all the brothers died
I'm the only like Wow to [ __ ] my
family's extinct no I'm the only son see
we out here baby I don't know if it
works I hope women get drafted as well
except for my fiance cuz she could
barely do a push-up
she is not saving anybody not yet she
will be doing those soon very soon but
yeah I don't I don't know if I heard it
was 35 and I don't think I could do it I
think I would just go to jail people
will call me a traitor they would say
that you're the next Muhammad Ali
Mohammed Ali didn't do it yeah and I'm
basically yeah you have to change your
name wouldn't come out though yeah you
have to have a different name I know
Cassius Clay good guy just thought of it
right now oh my god yeah Cassius Clay's
my name is oh that sounds really famous
yeah like a butterfly run like a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
do you think that you would go if you
were called to go into if you were
drafted you would do it Nick you are you
know what my American brethren Wow I
think I would they could be singing and
I'm proud to be an American because I
probably be worse right I'd go to
military jail I don't know because it'll
be filled with people just like me and
we just be high-fiving each other yeah
yeah five years old he hates us
it's all good I'm hungry yeah or I would
try to leave I would just go like I
don't know if Mexico anymore because
Mexico's like basically as a war going
on down there - everywhere - the war is
that for Canada it's cool yeah I wonder
yeah actually I'd have to do even more
research so I don't know yet put a pin
on that for me I don't know you think
you could kill somebody I don't know I
really don't I don't think I don't think
I don't know if I can or not
I just yeah I think you can it's
something I think Nick can do it is the
killer in your eyes you got killer eyes
sometimes when someone if like if I'm
behind them in a car
they don't signal then yeah I could kill
them but if it's like a war context I
don't think so no I think Nick would
would be the guy that like snaps and
like like starts liking kilowatts like
here take this gun you'd be like nah use
knives cuz I can see them I want to hear
their body that would be this dude in
war I think that would be here mad dude
yeah why I think you'd be that guy
how about that yeah that's pretty good
combat so I'll get the bird
you just got burned and leave the
podcast yeah I don't know man like it's
weird because like he yeah you know it
somebody trying to kill me I might be
able to kill him yeah but I don't want
to be put in the situation where I have
to do that [ __ ] I can't I can't go to
war ma'am nah I can't go to prison the
war I can't do any of that [ __ ] dude
like like his [ __ ] I heard I heard Tim
Kennedy talk on the podcast we're on Joe
Rogan's podcast where he was talking
about how when he was in Iraq he there's
these guys I guess he called him a
insurgents or whatever the term is he
they threw battery acid on these kids
that like lived in the local village and
he goes you know what we found those
guys and we murdered them I was like
that I can get on board with I feel like
if there's any like instance of like
crazy wrongdoing I feel like I can murk
someone for that but if it's just to
like just kill somebody and in a
situation I don't think okay you know
the interesting thing about that is like
I think when I hear those stories III
feel like he's a very virtuous person
Yeah right like Tim Kennedy is a man
like he's dope he's very virtuous he
believes that America is this shining
beacon of light yeah that they had
there's there's terrible [ __ ] that's
going on and that he's seen where people
throw battery acid on people he's
chilling children you know but you know
there's also video clips of American
soldiers just shooting civilians and
laughing yeah so is he gonna also speak
for those soldiers that are killing
regular civilians for [ __ ] fun and
giggling about it yeah so he doesn't
represent all he doesn't represent the
virtue of the American military he is
that guy and maybe the people that he
was around but there's also a lot of
footage of people just [ __ ] killing
and maiming people all right which is so
which is
definitely so you know I don't like I
don't I can I say just like everybody
condone worn [ __ ] specifically because I
don't want to go yeah but it's also it's
like you know it's it's one of those
things where you know you'd like to say
it's unnecessary because I don't know
that's yeah exactly I don't know that's
that's the main thing is that there's so
many moving parts who knows exactly dude
I had a hard time killing a mouse like I
had to kill him mouse like a month ago
and it was like yeah that's like the
same price we went like [ __ ] like
sorry god we're doing this even when we
went fishing sometimes I felt like a
little uneasy I'll tell you this I don't
give a [ __ ] about it
those little walks I could slice them up
all day yeah I would just play with my
child after hey kids it's like they got
no soul pigs weren't so [ __ ]
delicious I was feel really bad yeah
it's just pigs are like after I saw a
pig in real life I was like [ __ ] you
got human eyes TIFF TIFF doesn't eat pig
because of that reason
it is a human eyes reason she said so
bomb the movie babe there's a ball trick
Tiffany I'll trick there so Bob they are
really good I'll try to trick TIFF into
eating a pork but she won't people
always try to put up these moral stance
statements they go well what if human
tasted good and I'm like don't ask me
that
yeah don't ask me that I try it but like
if you had it like shoot a pig in the
[ __ ] head we had that be rough would
you have to be in the pigs like mark all
right going and you're like I can do it
maybe to like a wild boar with tusks
cause it's like trying to attack me and
kill me
I was sliced that [ __ ] in half like an
anime cartoon yeah with the sword
because there's a slides up yeah I was
slicing and and the [ __ ] paper is
still angry at me charging and he's
running and then he just stopped the
[Laughter]
Japanese pig
I gotta watch more anime dude database I
should really dope I like anime I like
it there's I mean if you find an anime
that has a really good production
company behind it it's a it's a film
it's a [ __ ] yeah dude yeah and it's
dopest and you recommend only one I've
seen recently is one punch man I try to
watch attack on tight you should watch
one me held Demon Slayer you can see it
on Hulu the animation is very unique in
the stories really good it's it's pretty
[ __ ] dope I I get it weirded out when
the anime just has like just a random
tip that just pops up and it's just joke
I'm like what is this yeah what's up
with that dude Japanese people love they
call it like fanservice so it's like
some guys like that [ __ ] they get off on
this [ __ ]
yeah they love the big tits that are
like barely covered up with a little
anyway no Japanese women looks like that
ever
yeah yeah because all the girls in the
anime have straight teeth
he's not kidding though no talk about
that Japanese people and bears people
can battle for the worst teeth ever like
straight up and I look at my teeth I
don't know my team is it like worse than
you it's pretty bad there's switch of
accents from British to Japanese very
good taste some men I'm racist i
scrutinize races specifically behind
cool nobody yet their teeth are pretty
[ __ ] up man I don't know why like I
guess like I don't know why I like
dental care is not a big thing like in
your head or like Europe these don't
give a [ __ ] just too good at everything
else they just probably don't have time
shame up then did you pay well I want to
go up into Japan no I want to go
Japan is dope number one no I got all
there is way more than there's air B&B
czar relatively cheap if you're in Tokyo
and it's a fun [ __ ] time baby really
yeah I heard I heard it was crazy
expensive actually it's not not any more
like we're talking about that's like ten
years ago
okay well yeah clan was way better than
ours so like I think they're dollar was
like twice as much as ours so we would
we were [ __ ] but their economy take
nation decreasing bang
that's why they're pushing their tourism
super hard their shits really cheap you
can get like you know like like all Toro
sushi right like the belly of the tuna
like you'll get like two pieces over
here will cost you like 20 bucks over
there it's like four dollars oh we're
going tomorrow yeah I'm actually down to
go cuz they want if it's on let's let's
make it happen do you go so the crazy
thing about awareness and what people
don't know about like like Japanese like
seafood is [ __ ] in Japan so there's
there's tuna and it shipped a certain
place right so the reason why tunas
cheaper over there is because that's
where most people eat it so he gets
shipped there first and we're like
America is like the one of the last
places that gets tuna and that's why our
tune is hella expensive that's why
they're Toro belly is like [ __ ] $4
damn dude
dropping knowledge baby do you wanna
know about tonight
let me [ __ ] enlighten you about this
a and now she the [ __ ] yeah she switched
it up she went from Veronica the Chola
July [ __ ] head off the phone for a
second let me explain to the man you
know I look at this trade better
I know ceviche with [ __ ] donut [ __ ]
[ __ ] big I do not that big I [ __ ]
that's just way better I swear don't
know why the Hosur different did you
know I think you know more Spanish than
you know [ __ ] a mandarin i do i do
know more Spanish I've been like
practicing sentences of the TIF but but
he must try some right now
yeah in front of Mexican please I mean
number a sneak I mean you just said my
name is Nick are you
I'm nervous too I'm slowly how he speaks
Spanish she sounds like he's 50 years
old called a rocking chair brett-o in a
cigar euro it's man she's like why are
you talking like that I don't know I've
been watching Coco a lot you guys watch
Coco Coco Coco made me cry Coco me me
every time I watch that makes me cry
yeah me too honestly I like I'll watch
on my daughter and I have to I get up so
good can't I got I got I'm gonna cry I'm
gonna start our spanking her so she can
fight the part of that I didn't cry
throughout the whole film until the end
oh yeah and he sings a song of music
unbelievable when he gives him the big
change the lyrics I'll be better we just
ruined the whole film watches movie yeah
oh yeah terrible wait what other Spanish
do you know what else have you learned
like biblioteca pretty good I want you
to say full set to smiling sunny elbow
mother alo
tips a godparent God dad calls me a
monthly mile really was that me alright
Inc it's hard yeah it's the arse that
get me yeah it's yeah and it's on the
spot so I'm a little nervous because
it's like oh my god I gotta I gotta I
gotta make sure TIFF knows that like you
know I could speak a little Spanish I
can't
mm-hmm
I could try it again this full sense is
this time full sentences say something
to me back give me a [ __ ] let's have
a conversation right so you walked in
it's a sunny day it's 3:00 p.m. just
[ __ ] I go in a lighter in the air
okay ceaselessly dos anos my favorite
fight I just said what did you do today
he said to you what'd you do today and
you're like two years how about you're
asking me how many years I've been sober
and I said you just felt like you had a
concussion that's [ __ ] conversation
oh it's like an ape what you know wake
up so hot are you guys hot I'm just like
steaming it is a little warm in here did
what I think this guy's weren't a jacket
he's crazy
oh you know what it is Metis because I'm
not nervous getting grilled as you said
you spoke Spanish and you don't know
what did you do today it [ __ ] yeah I had
a home run I had a home just give me so
mad when she watches this if she does
watch there are people in this world who
were hyper confident about stuff for no
[ __ ] reason a shout out to Pat for
just never see somebody like a lollipop
Center right back on the rapper it by 32
years of living hey bro you 11 years old
save it for later
[Laughter]
twenty more minutes here with you guys I
just need a little orange you like that
dude that's having a conversation with
his girl from us nothing serious said
there's like food in front of us no Mike
you
babe are you seriously eating that as
I'm talking about my mother died just a
lollipop you put in the hole all the way
throughout the whole you see his eyes
shifting toward this [ __ ] orange
lolly
I have thought about it a couple times I
don't want to disrespect them oh the
conversation is over here bro don't look
like I need it I just heard on the bike
yeah for all the listeners at home
anytime watch how many times he he put
the lie pop in his mouth rickets if we
could turn the camera but you we can't
but this dude has Smarties three
lollipops and one unopened lollipop on
the table that owned up and well that's
good though right that [ __ ] was tight
dude that was the most like this thing
I've ever seen in my life like they're
paying attention to each other this is
perfect that let me tell you this story
what was that smells like citrus in this
room suddenly was the dopest thing I've
ever seen in my life you know what the
funny thing is we actually had a topic
for this podcast and I completely forgot
oh it wasn't talking about Ricky Gervais
probably the same for the next hour all
right guys well that wraps up this
podcast I'm sweating so why don't we
lollipop Patrick they can find you
I just saw my Instagram's my name is
just Patrick dot e dot Reilly and yeah
that's where I have my shows and [ __ ] I
put videos of this [ __ ] loser
speaking Spanish honestly two years so
yeah have you been hey what's your name
brother to you
is both Magnus a mockery oh you Molly
album I rolled the arse
Mike glad you could smell a hard word
that is art that's hard by saying glass
glass is what you get scared these guys
always trying to [ __ ] tickle me do
your time you know maybe once in our
lives which is pretty gay but trust is
good do you know how to say glass in
Spanish nah that's a hard word as I say
it's even when I say I feel like I sound
like [ __ ] Count Dracula because it's
a B video video bead video I'm not it's
like a PR it's hard be that you'll be
video fast is mean but like sometimes I
[ __ ] it up too so I have to go like
video
it sounds like I'm saying video that's
how you say glass in Spanish no party
video video that was hard the DRS
heartbeat video be video lead the real
meet the real you like your face is too
yeah I feel like track you're smokin
broken be broke if they find you [ __ ]
video yeah you can find me on a neck
tear on Instagram everybody go to his
Instagram and tell him they actually
work for once in his life oh yeah dude I
swear I work he does because he somehow
uh pays his bills so I haven't figured
out how he does that I'm a trust fund
baby
I'm just getting a wish but you guys we
can find this on here every audio
platform iTunes give us a five stars you
can see us on Spotify stitcher everybody
all another [ __ ]
say what's up leave in the comments
below the trio is here today and we're
gonna say peace out peace your genius
[ __ ] two years baby